We’ve discussed some amazing things that
can be done with big data especially when
an individual’s information is compared
to a massive data set.
Some of those examples however, can feel like
they’ve crossed the line that separates
the impressive from the creepy.
That’s because privacy is an important issue
and a lot of these examples feel like they
may have crossed the line into private information
that people did not expect to have divulged.
People don’t want their personal information
to be public.
Indeed, over the last several years there
have been severe consequences to breaches
of privacy either accidental or intentional.
On the other hand, people do want to have
quality service and need to have good research.
One possible solution is to anonymize data
to make it anonymous.
By removing identifiers like names, addresses,
and other obvious personally identifiable
information.
But many such attempts have failed dramatically.
One of the major challenges of working with
big data is that even when a person attempts
to make the data anonymous by removing obvious
identifiers, it’s actually not impossible
to de-anonymize the data.
A really telling example of this came a few
years ago during the Netflix Prize, when Netflix
provided people with an anonymized data set
of user ratings on movies.
Two researchers Arvind Narayanan and Vitaly
Shmatikov were then able to take that information
and compare it with identified user ratings
on the internet movie database, IMDb.
They were then able to match people who are
identified by name on IMDb with anonymized
ratings on Netflix and connected two data
sets
A bigger challenge, there was another contest
that looked at social networks.
The contest included information that said,
this person who was identified just by a random
number, is connected to certain individuals.
From that, you get a social network graph.
That’s a picture that we’ve shown before
where each circle here represents an individual
and the lines are nodes that connect them
with other individuals.
What the researcher was able to do in this
case was again, send out a computer crawler
go through several social network sites that
were publicly available and they were able
to find simply by matching shapes, they had
no other information aside from the shape
with a diagram.
They were able to identify a social network
which actually came from Flickr, the photo
sharing site.
They were able to identify shapes in the Flickr
social network that matched the data in the
contest data, and they were able to then sort
of de-anonymize that data set as well, simply
by matching by geometry.
Even more dramatic example.
A researcher, Latanya Sweeney, showed that
she was able to purchase voter records for
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
What this included on the left is the name
and address, date registered, party affiliation,
and date last voted along with the zip code,
birthdate, and sex for each person in that
voter list.
On its own, that’s not much information
except you do find out the party affiliation
when they voted.
But, what she also found is that, with just
three of those pieces of information: the
zip code, the birth date, and the person’s
sex, she was then able to go to medical records
that were publicly available and matched them
up and find the person’s ethnicity, their
visit date, their diagnosis, their procedure,
their medication, and their total charge.
In fact, she was able to identify the governor
of Massachusetts from that data set, and get
his medical information.
Indeed, she was able to correctly identify
97% of the individuals in the medical data.
This was done about 20 years ago.
Fortunately, the regulations had changed since
then.
Now we have the health insurance portability
and accountability act, better known as HIPAA,
which has a lot to do with privacy regulations
in medicine.
HIPAA requires that a lot of different information,
about 17 major variables, need to be anonymized
or aggregated.
For instance, you can’t report a person’s
age, or you can’t give their birthdate.
You can simply say how many years old they
are.
If they’re over 89, you just have to say
they’re over 89.
You can’t give the zip code, you can only
give the state.
So, it becomes much larger groups and much
harder to identify people.
By doing so, Latanya Sweeney showed that,
there is only four one hundredth of a percent
of the people can be identified.
For comparison purposes, the probability of
getting strucked by a lightning is about one
out of 10,000, so it’s in the same vicinity
as that at risk.
The point here is that, while re-identifying
people in anonymized data set can be done,
it’s very hard to do it.
As Professor Sweeney has shown, if the information
is properly anonymized, it’s nearly impossible
to identify people.
The point of these examples is not to encourage
paranoia but rather to point out that care
needs to be taken when we’re working with
big data, especially when personally identifiable
information is present, in order to ensure
privacy.
is a start, but it requires some thought and
care to be done well, in order to provide
services and conduct research without crossing
the line into creepiness or into legal trouble.